oui la guerre en Ukraine
a créé une crise du gaz monsieur Poutine
a créé une crise du gaz en Europe c'est
un protestable c'est explose c'est de la
faute de ce conflit c'est la faute de
Poutine mais la crise d'électricité en
France c'est Monsieur Macron qui l'a
créé personne d'autre en abandonnant la
filière la filière nucléaire
c'est des responsabilités qui remontent
à bien responsabilité qui remonte très
clairement à 10 ans Monsieur Monsieur
Hollande sont ministre de l'économie qui
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron ou son jeune
conseiller économique s'appelle Emmanuel
Macron avant d'être ministre hier elles
ont été sucrées
le nucléaire avec avec courage face à
l'ensemble des difficultés
mais sincèrement quand vous expliquez
quand vous faites votre une loi c'est
pas vieux c'est en 2018 en 2018 monsieur
Macron expliqué à effet voter une loi
dans laquelle il annonce la fermeture de
14 réacteurs nucléaires quel message
vous envoyez
aux jeunes Françaises vous leur envoyez
le message qu'il faut pas aller
travailler dans le nucléaire que c'est
pas bien à l'heure à laquelle on parle
le ministère de l'écologie a encore un
label s'appelle un Green Label où il dit
dans lequel le secteur il faut investir
c'est bien ou pas bien d'investir et
bien toutes les boîtes qui investissent
dans le nucléaire sont exclus de ce
green Nobel
votre message
renouvelables ça nous concerne pas cette
message je ne dis pas ça du tout alors
je dis quand même que 1 on avait la
chance dans ce pays d'avoir le d'avoir
le nucléaire on avait 75 % de notre
électricité et simplement Monsieur
Hollande sur un comptable avant de
passer dans une émission de télé a dit
bon allez je suis pas capable de dire
100 % de renouvelable je vais dire 50 %
on va bien s'en tirer comme ça depuis
c'est devenu Adobe c'est absolument
sidérant donc oui il faut du
renouvelable probablement en plus mais
il faut d'abord du nucléaire si on veut
répondre à l'urgence des Français et le
renouvelable c'est pas que de l'éolienne
allemande moi j'aimerais qu'on travaille
davantage sur sur par exemple le petit
le petit hydro qu'on travaille sur
aujourd'hui on a aucune perspective sur
sur l'hydrogène vous avez des une région
la région aura avec Laurent Wauquiez où
on produit de l'hydrogène propre à
partir des des barrages électriques ou
des centrales nu cléaires il faut
investir là-dedans le gouvernement n'en
parle quasiment